apple is continuing slowing down their
ssds with the new M2 series of machines
like we saw yesterday with the M2 Mac
Mini and the 14 inch base MacBook Pro
now we have the six inch one right here
we're gonna go ahead and open up and see
if they're slowing down the ssds on a 2
500 machine this is the M1 Pro 2500
model 16 inch and as you guys could see
we have four memory chips right here for
storage plus an additional one on this
side even for the 512 gigabyte model now
let's go ahead and pop this one open and
I just want to say that a lot of people
complained when we complained about it
on the Mt MacBook Pro and M2 MacBook Air
those are 12 and 1300 devices and they
said that's not really Pro machine it's
okay to slow down the system and with
that we saw some pretty drastic
differences where even the M1 version
was faster than the M2 because of that
now let's see if we have that on this
new one and look at that Vadim
IR you guys can see we literally have
two storage chips here compared to five
so if you said it's okay on a 1200
machine being slower than a year and a
half old uh thousand dollar machine well
this is two thousand five hundred
dollars and I guess it's okay to give us
half the SSD speed or close to that on a
machine a year and a half two years
later that cost twenty five hundred
dollars so that is a disappointment now
I also want to point out just like with
the 14 inch we could see the difference
in the cooler block this uh heat
spreader cover that goes to the heat
pipes you see with the M1 Pro and the 16
inch it is much larger than the new M2
pro version and this little section
right here is actually uh just a little
cover for the metal underneath the
actual heat block is this so it's about
half the size and in tomorrow's video
we'll see how that impacts performance
and if we get any throttling and now
that we have them put together we could
get into the performance test and I'm
gonna do a bunch of real world tasks
that regular people in professional
Nationals use to see if we get any
slowdowns now before I test out our SSD
speed test I have to let you guys know
that we're doing a giveaway both a 14
inch MacBook Pro and a Mac Mini and all
you have to do is be subscribed to the
channel enable notifications and comment
down below and you can actually go back
to our previous videos and watch those
and comment and up to February 1st for
our upcoming videos to have more chances
to win so good luck to all of you guys
now let's go ahead and run this test and
as you guys could see we even have a
different name for the actual ssds
alright guys wow look at that we have
6887 compared to
3462. oh my goodness that's twice as
fast for the old machine that came out a
year and a half ago or so
um that's a big difference 16 inch 2500
machine now on the write speed it's not
twice as fast but we're getting closer
to that as far as performance and here
is the full metrics so you guys can see
it side by side but there's only one
category that the new M2 Pro it beats it
out and that is in large block random
reads everything else is worse and we're
gonna see how that impacts the real
world performance and now let's do a
file transfer test with our Benchmark
folder which we're going to use in
tomorrow's video putting these head to
head and seeing how much faster or
slower the new one is I'm going to grab
my folder drop it down and start the
timer now this is a large folder 222
gigabytes with all of our files and I
will say that both these ssds are fast
this one runs you guys saw it was like 3
300 or whatever and this SSD even though
it is Thunderbolt it runs at about 2 000
so we might not saturate the whole
amount but the way the ssds work is you
don't have the full portion being full
speed after you saturate enough of it it
will slow down because of SLC caching so
we'll see if that affects it right there
you guys saw it actually just slowed
down now it's at 854 megabytes second
780 even though the SSD itself can do
about 2 000. now that is just because of
the SLC cash that I talked about and
with this one being slower out of the
get-go it could slow down quite a bit
more and then not refresh itself fast
enough whilst moving those blocks we are
almost done here we're recording going
from 600 to about 700 megabytes a second
at the end and that took three minutes
and four seconds and now for the M2 Pro
16 inch hit start as you guys could see
we are transferring at 1.9 gigabytes a
second we hit two gigabytes a second
there and so far I'm really surprised
that it has not slowed down it's running
at that full speed so I wonder oh I
shouldn't have said that it slowed down
has slowed down a lot okay we hit 200
there 100 there oh my goodness what the
heck it stayed uh full speed longer than
this one which is a good thing a very
good thing but I thought it would not
slow down but now that it's slowing down
you guys could see running at 400 300 we
saw 200 and 100 that's very slow and the
way this works is almost like a highway
system we have four or five chips here
compared to two so if you don't have
that much traffic going across a
two-lane Highway like the M2 Pro 16-inch
that could be fine or a free weight but
when you have a lot of traffic going on
or applications you're using swap you
have a bunch of traffic well you're
gonna have a traffic jam with two lanes
compared to having four or five with the
previous generation we're almost done
here you guys are seeing we're running
out 265 megabytes a second compared to
six seven hundred so bam we are done and
even though at the start here it ran at
full speed for quite a bit long longer
than the previous one once it's slowed
down it slows down dramatically and we
have a time of four minutes for the M2
Pro Macbook so even though the
difference isn't as great as with the M2
MacBook Pros and MacBook airs because
these ssds are quite a bit faster than
our external we are still noticing about
25 percent difference in performance now
before we get into the real world
productivity test I've got to talk about
the best magsafe iPhone case I have ever
seen the magic stand case from our
partner case coup not only is it
surprisingly slim and durable but it
comes with a very strong 48 Magnet Maxi
Fring that actually doubles as a stand
just pull out the ring to use as a
finger grip or as a stand for watching
videos at any angle between 40 and 120
degrees and the best part is that it
folds back completely flush with the
case so you can still use it with your
max save Chargers and accessories so use
the link below to get 23 off your order
today and now we're gonna test out
Lightroom photo editing and I'm going to
start by importing some photos from my
30th birthday party we have 500 of them
I'm going to drag and drop it here it's
going to select all these photos and
then we are going to hit import and
start our timer so as far as the initial
previews it looks like the new Mt Pro is
grabbing those faster but with that look
at this we're at 96 degrees Celsius
already with the fans on compared to 78
with the fans on on the older one now
it's going to be interesting to test
with our performance benchmarks so it
looks like once it finished fetching
previews it was done importing I'm not
sure if it's just the preview file
that's using but the new M2 with the
slower ssds did that faster it took 58
seconds compared to a minute and 13.
that is 32 faster which is great next
I'm going to go ahead and Export 499
photos that we have here now keep in
mind we have nothing else open we don't
have any web browsing tabs any other
applications that you would typically
have open in the background so we're
going to get a baseline we hit export
start our timer and we are off now right
away we could see that we're using about
60 50 60 of the CPU and about 94 of the
GPU on the Owen Pro and here we're at 96
Graphics so they're fairly close but of
course with the M2 Pro we have two extra
efficiency cores and all of those cores
are faster more powerful and we have
three extra Graphics cores that are also
clocked higher now this does of course
read from the ssds and it writes to it
as well but if we take a look at it
there's really not that much data that
is being pulled most of load is on the
other part now like I said this is our
Baseline so once we get some other
things open we'll see if the slower ssds
slow us down once we get into swap now
of course we are testing out the ssds
but if we look at the data that's being
transferred it is very little so most
most of it's loaded on the CPU but this
is our Baseline and looking at the Swap
right here both systems are writing to
the SSD because we don't have enough RAM
both these have 16 so here we're using
5.6 gigs of SSD for Ram or as RAM here
we're actually using more 6.2 so even
with 16 gigs and nothing else open at
all on the system we are using those
ssds a swap alright we're done the M1
Pro 16 inch took 5 minutes and 28
seconds compared to 4 minutes and 49
seconds for the M2 Pro that gives us a
difference of 13 and a half percent in
favor of Mt Pro but the weird thing is
the CPU is 20 faster supposedly and the
graphics 30 faster so we would expect a
25 to 30 increase but we're only at 13
and of course we have nothing else open
and when I'm using a system I usually
have between 10 and 20 sometimes 30 tabs
but emails even more I have multiple
applications open I never have just just
one thing so now we're going to go ahead
and open up some other things in the
background just like everybody else
would especially professionals so now I
have 15 tabs opened up in Google Chrome
I have about 30 on my personal Mac right
now we go even higher but we wanted to
keep it simple and these are just some
basic web browsing tabs I have some
websites that I like looking at and
checking out we have IGN here for
example a good amount of media and then
I have YouTube analytics which I always
have open regular YouTube and something
playing in the background for music uh
just you know audio podcasts all that
kind of stuff I have my Google Drive and
some email opened as well which is
always open so now let's go ahead and
open up Lightroom once again
bam everything loaded up exactly the
same which is great and let's hit export
and see if there's going to be any
differences with just some web browsing
tabs open no other applications and this
time around we're using 10.5 gigs of
swap on the M1 and 9.9 now 10 on the M2
so you guys could see even 16 gigs of
RAM is not really enough on a system
like this we would wish if Apple would
just raise the bases get rid of the
eights go up to 16s and just give us
more because both these systems
definitely need to get into that now I
know about you guys but I never sit
around waiting for renders to happen I
always go do some web browsing answer
some emails so let's take a look what
the responsiveness is like with both
systems have the same specs so here we
can switch between a few different tabs
let's go to IGN and as you guys could
see it looks like the M2 system oh not
that time that's time the M1 was faster
so far it's trading blows sometimes
they're the same like that one
oh right there you guys saw the M2
slowed down because it has to read that
from the SSD
a little bit slower there how about we
go to our Google Drive
right there the M1 read that instantly
this one you could tell there was a
delay opening it back up getting back
into Lightroom it's hard to tell which
one's winning they're fairly close and
some people ask well why don't you have
web browsing tabs open in all of your
tests well some people say to do it some
people say not to do it so usually we
test one application but of course most
people are multitasking and doing
different things and if you want to see
how 16 gigs compares to 32 with these
systems make sure you guys are
subscribed because we will be making a
video like that oh my goodness guys this
is not the best let's wait for this to
finish and I'll give you guys the times
so the brand new M2 Pro 2500 machine
took 7 minutes and 57 seconds and the
old M1 Pro takes six minutes and 47
seconds that means that with those 15
tabs open and exporting is 499 images
and doing some multitasking
it took way longer and now instead of
the M2 Pro being 13 faster the M1 Pro is
17 faster uh once we're multitasking
with that open so it flipped by a lot
and both of these are the basics in inch
so we have 512 16 gigs of RAM the M2 has
better CPU and GP performance but the
M11 which means yes the SSD performance
was impacting and is impacting the M2
machine evadeem I thought that 15 tabs
wouldn't be enough you know we use a lot
more I have more than 15. and we always
have multiple programs open not just
Lightroom so that is crazy and that just
tells us if you're doing stuff like this
you're multitasking you definitely want
to go up to one terabyte SSD to get the
same performance as we had a year and a
half two years ago uh or you should also
be getting 32 gigs of RAM so I'm excited
for that comparison as well I think this
time around with the Mt Pros 32 gigs is
going to make a bigger difference than
it did before but now let's go ahead and
test something else and now we're going
to test professional Web Design Software
figma and this test was provided by our
partner 500 designs which does
incredible designs first I'm going to do
is just zoom in here and this is a web
based application it's a very typical
website so pretty smooth there let's see
what the M2 Pro does also nice and
smooth let's see how long it takes to
reload we got a little bit stuttering
there didn't take much to load that up
by the time I zoomed in the quality was
good let's check this one
actually a little bit worse there I did
zoom in more so and I selected 12 web
pages here and we are going to run an
export so let's get started so the M1
Pro took a minute and 58 seconds to
export Let's test out the M2 Pro and it
looks like it took a minute and 37
seconds compared to a minute 58 which is
actually the same results that we got on
the 14 inch Bend models
um so it looks like the CPU doesn't
really impact it that much having the
extra cores the graphics cores or even
having stuff loaded in the ram
um it's not making a difference which is
great for web designers now one
interesting thing is that the M1 Pro is
using 10.4 gigabytes of the SSD as RAM
for swap whereas the mtubers
consistently clearing stuff out faster
and using less I don't know if it's more
efficient if it's just clear stuff out
in general and that could be helping
stuff out so let's go back to Chrome
Chrome and let's see if we have any
performance differences any
responsiveness differences so far
everything looks to be identical now we
don't have anything in the background
right there we just saw that the M1 Pro
had to reload that and definitely took
longer so the memory could be more
efficient with the new M2 Pro chips
going to Google Drive Right There
our M1 system had to reload that whereas
super fast with the M2 even though and
actually maybe maybe it does make sense
why it's faster maybe that is here in
the swap where here it cleared out other
stuff to make room for it either way the
M2 Pro is doing better and now For You
video editors let's see if we have a
difference when we are multitasking and
we're near video editing now this is
standard compressed footage very very
easy to play back and I think
it's actually preset to better uh
performance not full quality like we
have on this one but neither one of them
should have any issues I'm actually
going to go ahead and press this L key
to play back faster which is what we do
sometimes when we're editing and here if
we take a look we're using 70 of the GPU
68 now compared to 48 on this one
because it does have three more Graphics
cores and they're more uh they have more
performance with higher clock speeds in
general and I'm going to go ahead and
Export uh this five minute project once
again very easy but most editors work
with footage like this looks like they
are almost done and they're running
practically the same bam they finished
the same exact time 2 minutes and 23
seconds which is maybe one to two
seconds slower than if we only had Final
Cut open so here we're limited by the
encoders that's the slowest part which
is why the systems were not being maxed
out so to make it a little bit tougher
here we have Canon c200 footage and this
is just a one minute project with some
regular effects if you're grading the
footage and we're going to go ahead and
Export this as well and we'll see if
this is limited by the encoders or just
by the performance of the systems which
of course with the M2 series we have a
lot more CPU and GP performance we're
getting close to being done here and
both these systems fly through this
compared to my fifteen thousand dollar
Mac Pro and we got a difference of two
seconds a minute and seven compared to a
minute and nine so the empty Pro was
quicker but that's just about two
percent quicker so not 20 to 30 percent
quicker with the extra performance so
what I'm going to do now is close
everything else in the background close
the web browsing tabs and we'll run this
again so we have everything closed let's
hit save to start exporting and see if
we have any differences in performance
alright that is done and both systems
were one second faster a minute and six
seconds and a minute and eight and now
uh that just shows us that unless you're
doing something that's very Ram
intensive like we saw in Lightroom or
other applications that you might be
using that are Ram intensive or for
example if you use uh parallels or other
virtualization which eats up a lot of
ram well then for most tasks you're not
going to see a big difference but if
you're doing a lot of Photoshop with
tons of layers other photo processing
other apps you can definitely see it
even with just 15 tabs open so we would
say if you know you're using a lot of
ram make sure that you do get from 512
up to a one terabyte then you get the
extra storage or you just upgrade to 32
gigs of RAM which will keep a lot of
that out from using your SSD and that
way you'll get a benefit so if you guys
want to see 16 gigs of RAM compared to
32 go ahead and click that subscribe
button make sure you guys comment on
this video and the previous ones and the
upcoming one funds for our giveaway
which we're announcing on February 1st
thank you guys for watching let us know
your thoughts are you okay with this SSD
downgrade we'll see you guys in the next
one
[Music]